And the answer, of course, is that modern DRAM systems
such as the ones used by high-performance GPUs transfer large chunks of data per transaction,
and therefore, if you can coalesce your memory request by many threads
that are performing a transaction at the same time, then you'll get many more useful bytes out of that transaction.
So the second statement, that DRAM systems transfer data in many small chunks, is simply false,
and the third statement, that GPUs have no on-chip caches to prefetch data, that's also false.
Modern GPUs do have on-chip caches,
although it is the case that prefetching data is not a particularly effective strategy for GPUs.
The caches are quite small considering the number of threads that are trying to use them,
and so you can't really afford to speculatively load data that some thread might use.
Okay, you have tens of thousands of threads that are actually trying to use those caches to hold data,
so prefetching is not an effective strategy, and this is also not a correct answer.